one of the academic institutions that i
had the combined fortune and misfortune
to teach at is fayetteville state
university down in fayetteville north
carolina not to be confused with the one
in arkansas also fayetteville state
university and i got hired in
2008 at the rate of assistant professor
i was brought in on a tenure track line
and i the reason i had to get into that
is my prison teaching job had ended
because the state of indiana had phased
out
upper level you know college
liberal arts prison education that's a
whole other story and so i had to get on
the job market rather quickly
at a rather inopportune time and
fayetteville state university was the
best place that made me an offer so i
moved from indiana all the way down to
north carolina
leaving my my family behind and getting
a little apartment and when i arrived
there
i found one of the most dysfunctional
places that i've ever taught in or been
to
i've found more since but fayetteville
state university was kind of in a mess
the chancellor was in the process of
being fired we showed up and we didn't
even have contracts
and one of the things that was part of
the general dysfunction there
was we we knew faculty
were expected to keep office hours and
we didn't have offices
and there was like no updates or signs
about when we would actually get offices
or how this was going to work and the
old-timers would all give us the same
old line oh don't worry you know the
institution will take care of you sooner
or later and it was you know associated
with this sort of southern everything
works out if you let it go nice and slow
and don't rock the boat kind of kind of
old boy thing and those of us who were
coming in from other places were like no
we need offices you said we'd have
offices
where are they get working on this
and eventually they did put us into
offices because what they did is they
took an old dorm
where there was already some things on
the first floor some administrative
offices and then they took all the new
faculty hires
or at least as many of them as they
could
and they put us into what were old dorm
rooms in this long corridor on the
second floor and actually that wasn't
too bad because then you know i had my
own office it had outlets it actually
had a sink in it and a closet which was
kind of nice so now you know things are
starting to look up you know having a
sink meant that i could actually like
make my own food there because i had a
hot pot and you know having a closet
meant that i could actually put like
dress shirts and suits and ties and you
know dress shoes in there and then i
could i could walk to campus which was
about three miles and you know i'd be
all hot and sweaty because it's
fayetteville north carolina so it's
always hot there except for you know a
few months in the winter and even then
it's you know very rainy and humid and
then i would change into my work clothes
and
teach my classes and go to my meetings
and stuff like that and then i would i
would walk home from there
and so that was kind of nice and i
actually spent quite a lot of time in my
office and i got to know the people in
the hallway and it was fun because they
were from different disciplines there
was me and the other new philosophy hire
michelle carpenter who was next door to
me and then there were some english
people and communication people and
nursing people and all sorts of other
things as well i think there might have
been a history person in there
and so we'd all get to know each other
and i like that that sort of thing so
anyway long story short i'm now about a
year in and i've got this kind of mo of
you know doing things on campus and then
going home from there and spending a lot
of time using my office as a home base
and i'm there on a tuesday or wednesday
night and there's going to be a concert
performance one of the things about
fayetteville state university that i
really did like is they had they had
some pretty outstanding music programs
and the
the main like theater building where
they did all the
you know theater and concert hall stuff
was a short walk from my office so what
i would do is i would you know catch up
on work and then around you know 7 or 7
30 whenever it was i would i would head
over
and go to the performance and then you
know i'd go back home that night and so
i'm sitting there in my office
and i'm working on something i don't
remember exactly what it was and i
noticed something happening and it is a
little disconcerting
i noticed that there's
water coming out of the wall
and it's the wall that i share with my
other philosophy hire michelle carpenter
who's not there
and at first it's like a couple little
drops
dripping beating up
and then it starts turning into a stream
and i'm like oh this this looks bad
so i'm in my office and i've got you
know books on the floor
and carpet and you know my office chair
in there and so i scoop everything up
and just to be safe i make sure that the
bottom shelf of my bookshelf i take
those books and i put them up somewhere
i think maybe on my desk or on top of
the bookshelf
and now the water is coming a little bit
more steadily it's turning into
a stream and it's you know starting to
flood my office and so i'm like well
this is actually pretty bad so i call i
think security
and they bounce me over to some
maintenance person and the maintenance
person on campus
comes over or maybe maybe it's the
security person and they're looking in
my room and they're like oh yeah this is
this is bad and you can like hear the
water now like rushing in the wall what
had actually happened was a pipe had
burst the pipes that fed those sinks in
our offices one of those pipes just you
know random occurrence had burst
and now we can actually see water coming
out into the hallway
from my
fellow philosophy professor michelle's
office which is locked at this time and
the person unlocks it and opens it up
and there is like a pool of water on the
floor that's coming out into the hallway
so i you know i say is there a mop
bucket around or something like that and
he tells me yeah go get a mop bucket we
figure out that and i start mopping and
i'm mopping in my room and then i'm
mopping in michelle's room and it's just
barely keeping pace with the amount of
water that's actually coming out now
i've done a lot of janitorial work in my
time and you know whether you're a
janitor or whether you're working in a
restaurant or whether you're in the army
you learn how to use a mop and a bucket
and to move pretty quickly if you need
to and so i'm keeping pace with this and
this this other person is like what are
we supposed to do
so they call the um the people who are
like the real maintenance uh engineers
or whatever and they're they're living
you know
in a different city
about 45 minutes away i think it might
have been sanford or something like that
and they're like well listen you know
it's going to be a while before i can
get there
i gotta have you guys go do something
and so
we lock up the offices and we're like
all right we'll we'll do whatever you
need done he says you're gonna have to
go
under the building
and
um turn off a valve
or like under the building do you mean
in the basement and he says well
it's not exactly a basement and here's
where the story gets really kind of kind
of crazy
so we go down and you know there's some
doors that have to be opened up because
obviously they don't want like regular
people going down there
where this um
underneath the building exists and you
know i'm from the midwest so i'm kind of
used to buildings having basements or
you can call them sellers whatever you
want and they're usually poured concrete
with cinder blocks and very often we you
know we take them and we turn them into
rooms or play areas or storage areas
they get used as part of the house and
you know if there's a tornado we go down
in the basement
well the south is not like that i mean
some parts of the south are
but large parts of the south are quite
different for somebody from the midwest
we go down and we open this thing up and
we're now like in the bowels of the
building you know where the foundation
you you would expect ought to be
and instead what we see is dirt
and it's not like a level dirt floor
it's more like you know there's there's
sort of like there's there's a big space
but the dirt floor has got like humps in
it some of which are like four feet high
and you know it's a vast area and then
you know this guy's giving directions
he's like okay you got to go over and
find the the shutoff valve for this this
thing and we're you know scanning around
with flashlights and we're like what the
hell is this
this is what's underneath the building
where where is the actual
foundation for this did they just build
this whole thing on dirt and it's
managed to stay
where it is all this time you know we of
course we don't have time to answer
those questions instead we got to go and
seek around and we're tramping around in
dirt and like dust is coming up as we're
walking
um and you know we're like i wonder if
we're going to find anything down here
you know something that we shouldn't
find and finally we find the shutoff
valve and now there's a challenge right
because it's not easy to turn the thing
and
finally we succeed in turning the water
off and me and this other guy are
looking at each other like
wow this is some really shoddy
construction stuff what's going on with
this you know so we we head up and and
get to my office and you know i start
mopping up the rest of what's there and
then pretty soon the other guy shows up
and uh and i'm curious so i i gotta ask
him is this normal for buildings here on
campus and like all around in
fayetteville you know that they don't
actually have
a
concrete
floor in the basement and and he says
yeah i mean that's that's just the way
it is for a lot of these buildings and i
was like they do have a foundation right
and he's like
yeah in a manner is speaking it kind of
depends how old they are what was done
with them who who did it you know these
these aren't all up to
code and you know the codes in that area
are not really like the codes where i'm
from that are a little bit more rigorous
you could say
and
of course i missed the concert
missed everything else you know i go
home get something to eat and that's
about it but it kind of stuck with me
you know and as i'm sitting there in my
office
um by the way the wall was all messed up
by that point you know they had to like
fix parts of it and go in and tear the
stuff out on carpenter's side and repair
the pipes and all that before they they
put the water on
um fortunately the you know
i don't even think it was drywall as
such it was some kind of plaster-ish
thing
was really eroded by the water on her
side so it was really easy to tear out
and you know you get everything back on
track try to keep it from mildewing and
molding
and uh you know then everything's back
to normal but that stuck with me you
know i knew that a lot of places in the
south because i lived in carbondale um
you know in in southern illinois which
is really southern in its culture and in
its you could say in its architecture
and codes and things like that i knew
that things you know
would be a little bit more lackadaisical
the further south that you went
but i i didn't think that pertained to
big public buildings like
dorms this was a dorm that people had
lived in for decades and decades before
it got turned into an office complex
so that's one of the many many stories
that i have about my three years down at
fayetteville state university living in
the city of fayetteville
and teaching all the different classes
mostly critical thinking that i did down
there this is the story of course of the
burst pipes and the water invading the
offices and the crazy dirt
whatever you want to call it the little
uh
kingdom of dirt underneath the building
that certainly wasn't a floor it was
more like walking around doing a hike
for what we were actually engaged in